92ページの4章 で あの
そちらのこのあの 4番4章では
あの 何を喋ってますかということは
この一応この 1書いてるこのパティニャーナ
趣旨というところで書いてるんです
チットゥッパダーナン イッチェワン カツワー サンガハ ムッタラン ブーミ プッガラ ベーデーナ プッバー
パラ ニヤーミタン パワッティ サンガハン ナーマ パティサンディ パワッティヤン パワッカーミ サマーセーナ ヤターサンバワトゥ カタン
で まあ心の正気の何て言いますか
最上 え？最上 情のように為り終わってですか
決勝正気の中 先身後身が決定すると
まあとにかく何言ってるかわからないんですね
で あのまあパーリ語で言えばブーミ プッガラ ベーデーナ
ブーミ ベーダっていうのは
この まああの心は生まれる
まああの 何と言いますか
この次元 まあその まあいわゆる欲界
色界 無色界とか プッガラっていうのは人々のこと
あの個人はいろいろ分けてあります
まあ一応まあ いくつかに分けてます
まあ一応凡夫と聖者と言えばそこで9つと言いますし
聖者の中でもあの善根あるないかによってまた区別されるし
あの凡夫の一般の人々の中にも善根あるかないかで人の区別されます
そういうことと プッバーパラ ニヤーミタン
プッバーパラ ニヤーミタンというのは
どんな心先に生まれて
次にどんな心が生まれるかと
まあ心にも順番があるんですね
で いい加減に心は生まれることはないんです
いわゆる心の法則なんですね
で まあその順番を説明すると
で それでパワッティ サンガハン ナーマというのは
心はどのように流れていくかと
心の流れ で 心がある決まってるパターンで流れていくんです
その流れ それからパティサンディ パワッティヤン
えーと どのように人が死んでから
まあ生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
その流れ 死んだところからまた生起する
ですから この死と生起ですか
だから人が亡くなって
それから生まれる人というのを生命が亡くなって
それから生まれると その流れもこれから説明しますと
あの まあ一応楽 まあ簡単に説明しますという意味なんです
このウッダランという言葉
最上で 最上にまたいろいろ
まああのテキストを読んでみてください
もっと分かりやすく書いてるかもしれません
チェ チャッカ マーティカー
チェ ワットゥーニ チェ ドゥアーラーニ チェ アラムマナーニ チェ ヴィンヤーナーニ チェ ヴィーティヨー チェダー
ヴィサヤッ パワッティ チェーティ ヴィーティ サンガヘー チェ チャッッカーニ ヴェーディ タッバーニ ヴィーティ
ムッターナン パナ カッマ カッマ ニミッタ ガティ ニミッタ ヴァセーナ ティウィダーホーティ ヴィサヤッ パワッテ
ィ タッタ ワットゥ エー トドゥアーラムマナーニ プッベー ウッタナエーネーヴァ
で ここであの 6つ6つにあのグループしてグループに分けて
この心の流れを説明しようと思ってるんですね
で 最初にあの チェ ワットゥ
六機ですね この六機は何ですかとこの前説明してあります
それはあの 何ていうのはチャック ソータ ガーディ ユーワーカーヤ ハデーという
あの 何といいますか 眼耳鼻舌身と言いですね
まあハデー ワットゥだから
まあ身という何とか書いてるかもしれません
それから六門と書いてあります
六門もまた同じことなんですね
まあその場合も眼耳鼻舌身意なんで
それを門入れるだけ 六所縁と書いてあって
アーランまで対象なんですね
6つの対象 それは目には色と耳には音と
そういう風に色声想味触法という 6つが六所縁なんですね
それから六識がございますで
ヴィンヤーナという言葉を使ってるんです
その場合は その場合も眼耳鼻舌身意にその色入れちゃうんですね
眼耳鼻舌身意に眼識と耳識と
そういう風に色入れちゃうんですね
パーリ語でいえばチャックヴィンヤーナ
ソートヴィンヤーナ ガーナヴィンヤーナ
ポッタッバヴィンヤーナ
マノヴィンヤーナなんですね
カーヤヴィンヤーナ ポッタッバヴィンヤーナじゃなくて
いろいろありますが それから説明
ヴィンヤーナからは説明が入ってます
3番目見てください チャックヴィンヤーナチャッカ
心の識の六処 チャックヴィンヤーナン
ソータヴィンヤーナン
ガーナヴィンヤーナン
ジウハーヴィンヤーナン
カーヤヴィンヤーナン
マノヴィンヤーナン だからチャック
ソータ ガーナ ジウハ カーヤ
マノという 6つに色という字を入れているんですね
眼識 耳識 鼻識 舌識 身識
意識と それから４に行きますが
それでヴィーティチャック
じゃあヴィーティを ヴィーティはどのように読むんでそれは
道ですか？読み方どうです？字です
読み方私はわかりませんだけど
適当に適当に読んでみてください
字でも路でもいいんですけど
読みやすい方でいいんですね
ゲンモンロでもいいし
ジモンロとかね ビモンロとか
一応ヴィーティっていうのは英語でいえばpathなんですね
roadではないんです
道路ではないんです path
いわゆるchannelみたいな意味で使ってるんです
まあヴィーティっていうのはstreetという意味ですけど
英訳ではどんな訳しているでしょうか
ちょっと見てみましょうか
[紙をめくる音]まあこちらはこの thought processes thought process という process ですね
訳してますけど thought path でもいいし
process だってちょっと言葉難しいだけですけどね thought
processes という
まあ日本語でこのプロセスというおなじみなんです
何かのプロセスですね
で path という言葉もね
まあ正しいと思いますけど
で いわゆる心の流れ 心の
あの うーんと 流れるプロセスは
いわゆる道は 6つありますと
いわゆるまあ 6つってすごい簡単なんですね
目の目を通して一つの心の流れがある
耳を通してまた心の流れがありますし
舌を通して心の流れがあるし
で 鼻を通して一つの心の流れがありますし
それから体を通してもう一つ心の流れがあるんですね
そういうふうに それから心を通して
また心の流れが 6つあるんです
その心の流れのことを言ってるんです
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
何か目で見たら 我々の心は一つの意識が
意識の流れが起こるんですね
何か音が耳に入ったら
ある意識の流れが起こるんですね
体に何か触れると そこにまた意識の流れが起こるんですね
そういうことなんです
で 次にこの5番目 あの 94 ページの5
ヴィセアッパヴァッティチャッカ アティマハンタン マハンタン パリッタン アティパリッタン チェーティ パンチャドアレ
マノドアレ パナ ヴィブータン アヴィブータンチャ チェーティ チャダー ヴィセアッパヴァッティ ヴェーリタッパ
これは境ですかね 境象気の六処
まあ境象気の六処と言ったって意味がわかりませんだけど
ヴィセアっていうのはこの対象
認識の対象 この認識の対象が認識主体にどのようにぶつかるかっていう法則なんですね
で まあ後で言葉を作りましょう
まあ今はちょっと言葉が出てこないんですけど
説明を聞いてから言葉は何か適当な言葉を作ってもいいし
こちらのある あの あの
こちらのテキストの専門用語では
境とこの境と書いているのはこの対象のことなんですね
まあそれは昔から仏教専門用語で
このヴィシェというサンスクリット語
パーリ語の言葉は境と訳すること決まってるんです
まあヴィシェっていうのは
まあ何て言いますかね
一つの縄張りみたいな意味なんですね
だから目の縄張りは いわゆる形なんですね
ものの形 耳の縄張りは音なんですね
まあそれで耳には味は全く味わえないんです
いくら美味しいものを耳に詰め込んでも
全く味は味わえないし
で 縄張り以外ですから
ですからヴィシェっていうのは
そのある働きを まあどこら辺で働きか
働け 働けるかということなんです
その意味でヴィシェというんです
それからだから耳だったら音の領域
まあヴィシェって領域ですね
まあ縄張りというその領域という意味で
そこでこちらで言いたがっているのは
そのその認識主体である主体というのはちょっとおかしい言葉なんですけど
認識基盤である眼耳鼻舌身に 6つの対象があるんですね
それは六処縁と言うんですね
だから目には色 形というものしか触れない
その形が目に触れる時も
いつでも同じレベルで触れるわけじゃないんです
耳に音が触れるんです
耳の縄張りが音 耳の領域は音
耳は音の領域の中で仕事しています
だからって耳にいつでも同じレベルで音が触れるということはないんです
ですから 音の客体の世界から見ても
こちらの主体的な体に触れる状況
それなりに変わっちゃうんですね
それを説明している 一応次に読めばわかると思います
アティマハンタンマハンタンパリッタンアティパリッタンと
で 五門には極大大小極小という 4種類があるんだと
五門というのは眼耳鼻舌身ですね
ということは 目には形が色
色が入る そこでこの色が 4つのタイプに入っちゃうんですね
1つは 極大 極大っていうのは
この色 外にあるこの対象がそのまま目に映る
で いわゆる外にある一定のデータ量があるんですね
そのデータの量が全部目に目に入っちゃうんです
それは極大というんです
それで このデータ量の半分以上入ると大というんです
半分か半分より少々少ないなると小と言って
それよりも 2分 4分の1ぐらいのデータしか入らない場合は極小と呼ぶんです
そういう 4種類なんですね
まあこう考えればこれ分かりやすい
例えばある絵があって
それは何か小さな紙で隠してるんだと
そのこの中に何が入ってるんですかとみんなに質問されたとする
それでみんなもうわからないと
じゃあ見たいんだと じゃあ見せてあげましょうと思って
まあ例えば 4 秒間 その隠してる紙を開けてあげると
で  4 秒経ったらまた隠しておくと
それで見てる人々には 4種類でそれ見られるんですね
ある人にはこの絵を 4 秒間も見ていることはできるし
ある人が 3 秒しか見てないし
ある人は 2 秒しか見てないし
ある人は 1 秒しか見てないし
そうすると 見た人々の認識が 4種類なんです
入ったデータ量によって
だから四秒間存在した目に入るデータの量がありまして
ですから そのデータはいわゆる光子といえば四秒間の光子の量なんですね
それで全部四秒間の巨大な光子
光子量が 素粒子が目に入っちゃったら
それは極大 半分以上入ったら大
半分ぐらい入っちゃうと小
半分もいく まあいわゆる四分ぐらい
四分の一ぐらいになっちゃうと極小と
それでなんでそういう説明をするかというと
それによって我々の認識の強さを決めちゃうんですね
だから この見た絵を四秒間見た人がより明確に知っているでしょうに
一秒しか見てない人が
人の認識がすごく微かなんですね
そういうことなんです
そんなに難しくないでしょうね
音にしたっても同じことで
それは難しい こういう風に説明すると難しくないと思いますけど
これはもう阿比達磨の無常論において
このものはどれぐらい
まあこう言いましょうか
その説明は後で出ますから
私は今ちょっと言いたくないんだけど
物質は一瞬存在するんですね
一瞬のみ で 心はもう一瞬なんですけど
物質よりものすごく短い
短命なんですね ですから
物質が一瞬存在していると
心が十七回生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
ということは 心の寿命より十七倍物質の寿命が長い
で まあだから私はそれはまあいい加減に説明して
我々物理学的に知っているものの速さといえば光の速さですから
で それはまあ生滅の速さに入れ替えちゃって
正しいかどうかはわかりませんだけど
もし生滅は光の速度で起こっているならば
心がそれより十七倍速く生滅しているんだと
だからこの だからこの人間の理解っていうのは
いつでもこの 何て言いますか
転倒しているんだから
理解はいつでも逆さまだから
あるものはないと ないものはあると理解するんだから
で 早く変わるものは本当に儚いものだと理解するべきなんですね
すぐ消えるものは で 逆に人間はすぐ消えるものに反して永遠だと理解する
ゆっくりゆっくり消えるものに出会って
ああ かわいそうに 亡くなったんだと泣いたりする
だから我々にはものがなくなると
消えると なるほど無常だと偉そうなことを言うんだけど
自分の心はものすごい強烈に変化しているのに
それには気づかないんですね
でも私はずっといましたと
私はここにいて 花が咲いて枯れていくのは見ていたんだと
だから永遠たる自分が永遠でない無常たる対象を観察していると思っているんですね
そこは仏教では転倒識だ
転倒認識というかね と言うんです
いわゆる逆さまだと考え方
全ての人間の知識はそういう風な
これ逆さまなんです 逆さまの世界で我々は学問を作って
科学を作って生きているんです
で まあそれはまあどうしようもないこと
で 仏教の世界では逆のことを全く違うんだと
あなた方が知っている世界と真実の世界はもう正反対だとと言って
堂々と言うんですね 人は素晴らしいというものには
仏教は堂々とまるっきり逆で素晴らしくはないんだと
綺麗だ清らかだというのは全く不浄だ
汚いんだ 醜いんだというんです
永遠だ 実体だというのは
まるっきり永遠ではなく
実体も何もないんだと言っちゃうんですね
人間が幸福だというものには
仏教は堂々と それこそ世の中にある一番大きな不幸だと
でもあれはもういい加減に逆説しているわけじゃないんです
それはこの認識の働きを見てから
そういうことは事実だから言ってるんです
心は短いのに 私たちはそれはものすごい長いんだと
と勘違いする で見ればすぐわかるでしょうに
もう瞬間で心変わっちゃうでしょうに
例えばこちら持ってきた花が枯れてしまうまでは
まあ 一週間ぐらいかかるかもしれませんだけど
花を見た瞬間で ああ良かったと喜んだ人が
次に何か大事なものを
花を植えたこのガラス瓶を割れたと
それで割れた瞬間ですごい悲しくなっちゃうんです
瞬間なんですね 花を見て
ああきれいな花だ それで入れようと思った途端
もう花瓶が割れてしまったと
滑っちゃって ああもったいない
嫌だと すごい高かったのにと
その瞬間で思っちゃうんですね
あの瞬間で綺麗だと感じたものと
ものすごい嫌な感じと
生まれてるのに でも花はその時でもまた元の通りにいるんでしょうし
ですから 物質よりどうせ心が早いのに
それは認めたくないんですね
で まあそういうことで
このアビダンマではこう言うんです
例えば目で色を見ると
色は 17 ポイント  17瞬ですか
生きてるんです 心と比べて
心の一瞬は 1と数えたら
心の寿命は 1であるならば
物質の寿命は 17 なんですね
ですから 物質が目に触れる物質があるということは
それは 17 瞬間生きているということ
それで瞬滅 瞬間 殲滅 瞬間消滅している心が 17回もあの色を見ていたならば
まあ巨大なんですね 情報量が
だから色の全ての姿が心は受け取ったことになっちゃうんです
で 色が半分年取った時
例えば10 10番目の瞬間で心がこちら見えるものあるんじゃないかと気がつく
それでもう 10番目の瞬間だから
あと 7瞬しか残ってないんですね
見るために その色が消えちゃう
その場合はやっぱり小というしかないんですね
小か大かどっちでもいいんですけど
まあ眼耳鼻舌身には物質触れるんですから
色声香味触という物質が触れるんだから
その物質が触れる場合は
この 4つの立場でほとんどの情報データを取るか
半分以上取るか 半分以下取るか 4 分の 1 ぐらい取るかということによって 4種類に分けてるんですし
その 4種類によって我々の知る量も変化するんですね
明確にするか まあそこそこにするか
どっちかとかね だからこの具体的に我々の役に立つようなこと言うと
ならば ものを明確に知りたければ
じっと聞いたり見たり考えたりすることなんです
いい加減で中途半端ではまるっきりきちんと理解はできないんです
例えば まあ子供でもちゃんと勉強したければ
ベースに大した能力何も要りません
じっとそれだけもう聞いていれば
そのまま情報が心に入って認識が生まれるんです
ベースに才能なんかあるの全然関係ないんです
だから他のことを考えたり
隣の人と喋ったりとか
行っちゃうと教える方の情報のものわすかしかすごくわずかしか入らないんです
だから何も知らないことになっちゃうんです
と そこであのマノウドアレパナビブータンアビブータン
心に何か考え方が生まれた時
その四種類に分けません
その場合は二種類に分けちゃうんですね
日本語では何といいますか
明瞭と不明瞭という二つに分けているんですね
対象が明瞭に映るか不明瞭に映るかと
パーリ語ではビブータアビブータという言葉なんですね
ビブータっていうのはもうすごくもう広げて
きちんとこのテーマがこの問題だと
このポイントだと 今考えているのはこういうことだと
きちんと明瞭に心に浮かぶと
あるいはもう何か喋ってるんだけど
何のために何について喋るかわからない状態もあるでしょうに
その場合は不明瞭なんですね
喋ることを置いておいて
考えることにしてみれば
自分が何か考えていると
あ こういうことを考えている
こういう問題を考えているんだとしっかりと知っている場合はあまり問題ないんです
それはちゃんとこういうこういうわけで
こういうこういうことでという風にちゃんと整理するんですね
ただ考えている 何を考えているかわからない
何のために考えているかと
わからない いや いろいろ問題あるんだから考えているんだと
どれぐらい問題あるかわからないし
そういうふうな状態は不明瞭な状態なんですね
そこでもわかってほしいのは
我々は心の中でいろんな問題やらいろんなことをやら考える場合は
心の中を整理した方がいいんです
今何を考えるか 今悩んでいる問題は何なのかとしっかりとそれをちゃんと分けて
あ これについて今悩んでるんだと
と それ見たら それについてちゃんと結論が出てくるんです
と考えたものはしっかりと整理したようになっちゃうんです
例えば 何かもうちょっとした不幸があったと
不幸があったらすぐ心が暗くなっちゃうし
で それで明確に私は買い物をしようとしました
その時はお金がなくなったと
それで他の希望した買い物はできなくなったとかなんとかだったら明瞭なんですね
問題は で 例えばご飯食べてデザートも食べたかったんだけど
もうお金がなくなったんだからデザート買うお金がなくなったと
で 明瞭にする で それを明瞭にしない人は
なんで私は不幸ではないかと
本当に今日はついてないとか
例えば今日はついてないとか
ものすごい大雑把ないい加減な言葉でしょうに
今日と言っちゃったら
そこで二十四時間もありますから
二十四時間はついていなかったんですから
それで不明瞭に対象を頭に入れちゃうんだから
やっぱりついてない 今日はついてない
この頃はついてない もっともっと
ものすごくもうモヤモヤ状態に来るんですね
そうすると ありとあらゆるもうついてなかったものはいろんなものをそこで関連性あるものは頭に入っちゃって
まあ悩んで考えて考えているんだけど
あんた何考えてる？本人もわからない
何のために考えているんですかと
それもわからない 考えた方に悩んだ末で何か結果があるかというと
全然結果もない だからこの認識自体が
だからもう世の中でみんなに問題ばっかしなんですね
だから我々テーラワーダ仏教でいうこのしっかりした思考っていうのはみんなに嫌われちゃいますけど
で 私はそれで反応として
そういう嫌われる人々をみんな嫌いと思ってるんです
かえって もう人間じゃないんだと
明瞭に考える何が悪いんですかと
だから大雑把でちんぷんかんぷんでもありがたやありがたやというふうに喋るのはみんなすごく好きなんですね
大変御利益がありますとかね
こういうことすごいありがたいことで
ありがたい仏法に出会いまして
皆様大変幸福でいらっしゃいますとかね
ありがたいってどういう意味かと明瞭にしてほしいし
皆様方大変幸福だと言ったっても
何が幸福だと それはもう何もなくて
ただこの知らないことをありがたがる
しっかりしないことをありがたがる
それは無知の道なんです
決して知識の道じゃないんです
いくら日本は教育的に世界一だと言ったっても
歩んでいるのは無知の道だから
結果はどうですかと では世界抜群の知識人いるかと
一人もいないでしょうに
ですから このやっぱりこの
基本的に我々この不明
不明確なこと 大雑把なこと
そういうファジー的な状態がありがたがっちゃう
それがもう日本の文化だと
そうああだこうだとか
偉そうなラベリングを貼って
ラベルを貼って貼って評価しようとする
それでひどい目に遭うだけなんですね
ですから この頭しっかりすることも大変大事なことで
まあ人と喧嘩したってもいいんです
喧嘩する時でも こういうことであなたと喧嘩するんだよと
そのポイントをきちんとしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから なんで夫婦喧嘩っていうのは絶えないんですかというと
何のために喧嘩するかと
互いにもわからないんですね
それでももうただ言いたい放題両側に行って言ってて終わってしまっちゃうし
だからもう一人一人でもね
夫婦の間 もうちゃんと明瞭に物事を考える人がいれば
そんなに長くその喧嘩はいかないかもしれませんだけど
例えばもう激しく喧嘩したっても
ちゃんとポイントを絞って
このポイントについて喋ればいいんです
例えば旦那さんがもう休みはどこかへ連れて行くって約束しましたと
じゃあ9時にもまあまあ10時に出発しましょうとか
そこでまあどこかへちょっとじゃあまあ10時までちょっと外へ出て外行ってきますと言ったところ
どこかの飲み屋さんに入っちゃって
酒飲んで酒飲んで帰ったの3時ですよと
ちょうどまあどうせ喧嘩になっちゃうでしょうね
そこでもうちゃんとポイントを絞って
こういうことについてもうさんざん喧嘩したっても構いませんし
そうじゃないんです 生まれた時からせーので喧嘩するんです
ですからもう喧嘩したっても喧嘩にもならないんですね
問題だらけで ですから
この認識の場合は 対象は種類に入るんです
明瞭不明瞭と ほとんどの
不明瞭に入っちゃって
もやもやもやもやもや考えてるんであって
何も役に立たないし で
それによって我々の認識が四つの種類に分けられるんですね
例えば認識っていうのは外の情報を知ることであるならば
眼耳鼻舌身入る情報は四種類になっちゃうんです
極大 大 小 極小と 意識に生まれる認識が二種類に分けられるわけです
その分析はいくらかは役に立つ分析ですから
覚えておいてもいいです
で 次にチットルーパイ六番目
心と識の寿命 カタン ウッパード・ティティ・バング・ワセーナ・カナッタヤン・エーカ・チッタッカナン・ナーン
ターニ・パナ・サッタ・ラサ・チッタッカナニ・ルーパ・ダッマナ・アユ
どのように表記するかと
小住滅により三刹那を一瞬刹那という
またそれら十七刹那が
刹那ですか 刹那ですね
すみません それら十七刹那が
表識 相識を除いた二十二色法の小住滅の寿命であると
で あの こちらこの説明はね
伝統的に昔 このお坊さんたちが考えてた
この注はまあ年まで書かれたものですけどね
まあ書いてありますけど
それブッダゴシチョーロもたまたま書いてるものはどんどん傍注して書いてあってますから
ちょっと見てください
これはそれ一段指？なんて言いますか
一段四の一兆分の1程度という極めて短いものであると
心の一瞬はね 一つの刹那は
この一瞬刹那をさらに細かく見ると
それは小住滅の三等分され
等分された3分の1に当たる時間を刹那と言っている
したがって小意などを少刹那
住刹那などという なお
この刹那を初刹那 その3倍である一瞬刹那を大刹那とも称する
で 一応こういう風に分けてはいますが
一般的に言えるのは この心の波動っていうのは随分短いもので
それ決まってどれぐらい時間かっていうのは秒単位でね
分けるわけじゃないし
例えばこれこの断紙というのは指をこうやって鳴らす時間だからね
どれぐらいですかね それは
秒は 1 秒かかりませんですから
で まあストップウォッチを
ボタンを押してすぐ消すとそのぐらいの距離なんですね
それも訓練次第にかなりもう早くできますけど
やっぱりギリギリのストップウォッチというのは
押したらスタートしてまた押したらストップだからね
まあまあそういう実験は私もやったことあるんだけどね
どれぐらい速さでこれ押せるかと
まあやっぱり0.3 0.1
あたりできるんだから
秒でね それぐらいの速さでまあ音は出ますからね
まあ一応今の現代コンピューターとか使っちゃえばね
時間というのはもう簡単に計れるんだけど
何にも役に立たない それでは
で なぜ何にも役に立たないっていうのは
もうこの指を力入れて出すというところには
心と物質はかなり変化しなくちゃいけないんです
だからこの一兆分の1とか
もうそういうのは一つの
もう単なる説明であって
別に何の根拠もないんです
だからただ言いたがっているのは早いよということだけなんですね
だから人々の理解できない速さが言ってるんです
[背景音]